foreign
[Music]
Minister already after less than 50 days
on the job I am resigning as leader of
the conservative party
[Music]
and we hear from the campaigners who
want more free school dinners it's
really important that your Feds well
every single day
[Music]
hi hello we're here as always for your
info it was only a few weeks ago we told
you about our new prime minister Liz
truss
she became prime minister after Boris
Johnson resigned thank you
but now she's resigned I am resigning as
leader of the conservative party so how
did it happen two weeks ago we told you
about changes to tax which is the amount
of money that people pay to the
government to provide for things like
the NHS the Army and other things they
decide to help with for example the cost
of heating I saw that Liz trust wanted
to reduce what people pay in tax that's
right even though by reducing the cost
of heating the government needed more
money not less money and that was the
problem the government would have to
borrow more money than they already do
billions more and that made Banks and
big companies nervous
it led to an economic crisis the most
basic things like milk and bread are
already getting more expensive and this
decision made the problem worse
so the Prime Minister had to deal with
her mistake she sat the chancellor of
the extractor quasi-quarten and brought
in this man Jeremy Hunt instead who
stopped most of the changes from
happening
many people thought she was the one who
needed to go I am sorry and that I have
made mistakes but she said she was
staying I am a fighter and not a quetter
up
as the pressure mounted for her to
resign Liz truss announced that she'd be
leaving after less than 50 days on the
job
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week so we'll have
another prime minister
[Music]
phone technology just keeps getting
better they can even detect soda
movement so say you're in the car that's
out of control and crashes one new model
will dial the emergency services to tell
them you're in an accident
that's a great idea well it would be if
it worked ambulances in the USA didn't
understand why they kept being called to
an amusement park until they found the
phones were calling them from a roller
coaster ride where the bumps and jerks
were confusing the phone ah I see the
problem great story though but is it
fake news or facts I'll give you the
answer later on
[Music]
did you know whether you get a free
school meal or not depends on where you
live in the UK we went to visit a school
in Islington in London where everyone is
guaranteed a free hot meal every day
[Music]
foreign
and we're just about to sneak into the
kitchen to see what's on the menu today
what's on the menu today today we've got
to mini pizzas is it important for kids
like me to get their free school lunch
it's a really really important because
it's good for you and it's good for your
education when you are hungry you can't
really really learn anything can you I
agree we are lucky we have a proper
kitchen so we get delicious food served
up every day
I love the pizza and I love the cheese
and the tomatoes
if you're really energetic after eating
that big munchy Pizza
I think it's my favorite time in the
whole six hours because you just sit
down chill eat talk with friends
we've invited praise oloria to our
school She's a young campaigner who
wants to see more of us get school
dinners this smells really good yes
praise is campaigning alongside famous
TV chef Jamie Oliver to ask the
government to serve up more free School
meals so do you think all children
should get a free school lunch and why
in Ideal World it'll be really good if
all children had access to free School
meals benefits of free School meals is
that kids like you they don't have to
worry about anything so they get to come
and just eat their lunch so when they go
into the lessons they don't have to
worry about being hungry or anything but
that's why at fight back we're trying
our best to really make sure that all
children that we need free School meals
have access to them so you can get a
nutritious and healthy meal every single
day so can free School meals really be
seen as priority at times like these
kids like you you are the future because
you're going to go on to do really
amazing things and all sorts of
different professions so I think it's
really important that your Feds well
every single day
[Music]
we thought we'd ask the people in charge
of our school dinners in each part of
the UK what they're serving up
first we asked them who they were so my
name is Mark Drakeford I'm the
pre-winning dog company the first
minister of Wales the first minister of
Scotland Nicola sturgeon was busy this
week so she asked the education
secretary to reply
there she is Shirley Ann Somerville
Shirley wrote to us there's an education
Minister for Northern Ireland too called
Michelle mcelveen
and finally for England we asked the
Prime Minister his trust before she
announced she was leaving but neither
she or her school ministers were able to
reply but government spokesperson gave
us this statement first we asked
everyone who gets a free school dinner
and from that we worked out the best
place to live in the UK for school
dinners at least we found out you're
most likely to get a free School Meal if
you live in Scotland
the first five years at Primary School
everyone gets a free school dinner and
very soon it will be every year at the
moment England comes next everyone in
the first three years gets a free school
dinner
but whales are about to take over by
2024 every child in every Primary School
in every part of Wales will be entitled
to a free school meal so you're least
likely to get free school dinner in
Northern Ireland neither England or
Northern Ireland have any plans to
change the rules but some of you are
entitled to a free school meal whatever
year you're in campaigners like praise
who we saw earlier think more people
need them she says 800 000 children
urgently need access to free School
meals the government said in England
we've expanded access to free School
meals more than any other government in
recent decades
they told us councils can decide what to
provide to families with their own
funding that's why at the school in our
report they have a free school dinner
every day your lunch really does depend
on where you live we also tried to find
out if the people who make the decisions
about our school dinners had eaten one
themselves well the last time I was
involved in school dinners I was helping
to serve and they looked absolutely
fantastic definitely Custard in Scotland
Shirley said her favorite school dinner
was mints and tatties oh and she doesn't
have custard on her pudding but in
Northern Ireland and England we couldn't
get an answer so either Liz truss and
her ministers like custard on their
pudding or not will remain a mystery
we all like to Doodle now and then but
this man has taken doodling to another
level
artist Sam Cox even calls himself Mr
doodle the doodling didn't stop until he
had doodled his whole house
but it wasn't as fast as a sped up
footage it took an amazing two years to
Doodle the six bedroom mansion wow
[Music]
now we all think Costco is the best but
imagine being told officially that your
school is one of the best in the world
this school in dunoon Scotland got the
news in a special award ceremony this
week
we wanted to know what is so special
about school
so we've got Leah Alistair Morgan and
yeah hi guys hi Congratulations by the
way thank you very much now we are what
was the award for our award was for the
community collaboration and it's been an
absolute honor to win it and Morgan I've
seen you playing bingo tell me what that
was about we decided to hold on online
bingo session for the elderly people
because they couldn't go to any Bengal
stations during lockdown and they just
really enjoyed it and the award also
focuses on your impact on the whole
world could you tell us more about that
we sent a bunch of pupils from our
school to showcase our app called
benue's battles and a huge event called
cop26 where important people like Greta
Thornburg was there
and how the app works is it basically
inspires and motivates regular people
around the world to reduce their food
waste through friendly competition
that's such a clever idea well done guys
and as well as being called best school
in the world you've also won fifty
thousand dollars how much is that in
pounds it's around 44 000 pounds wow
that's a lot of money that's we're very
lucky to be able to receive that kind of
money well congratulations on meeting
the rest of the world guys bye bye
[Music]
we searched the world for the best
stories
this is Lino he lives 5 000 miles away
but we still heard about his new carbon
free invention
so we asked him to tell us more
[Music]
our world is
50 years or less we will run out of
fossil fuels these important resources
pick up 80 of the energy we use today
how we power our world this is 15 year
old Lena from Frisco USA down in the
state of Texas
and he's tackling the world's big
problems
our current renewable energy resources
are not sustainable enough to replenish
the energy debt that fossil fuels once
provided us luckily there's a solution
to these problems like all good
superheroes he's come up with an idea to
help save the planet
imagine having the power to charge your
world at your feet literally kinetic
kicks 2.0 is powering our world one step
at a time Lena has come up with a way of
collecting energy while he plays soccer
or as we say in the UK football
all of my inventions have aspects that
can help our Earth and help our climate
the kinetic kicks of course are centered
around clean renewable energy accessible
to all the sole solution aim is to
prevent shoe waste like many inventions
it came about by pure tones one day
after practice my phone was dead and I
was unable to call my mom to tell her to
come pick me up I then thought back to
science class earlier in that week when
we learned about the transfer of energy
and how energy cannot be created or
destroyed it's only transferred from
place to place so I thought what if I
could transfer all the energy I just
wasted on the soccer field and did to
charge my phone that's how the kinetic
kicks was born
but how does it work
you step down all the energy collected
goes into a USB power bank and when
you're ready you can plug your phone in
and now it's charging
genius
idea that's why Lena's needed to help
reduce climate change and in a couple
weeks the world will meet again at cop27
to find more ideas cop stands for
Conference of parties it's a call for
the world readers to get together like
they did at cop 26 in Glasgow to see how
they can work together to limit global
warming here at FYI we want to make sure
that your voice is heard so we ask
members of our FYI news clubs to send
video messages to the world's leaders
[Music]
my message for world leaders is to take
action think about what other people
think and not what they want
don't mess it up
because what you're doing right now
that's going to be the entire plan for
our entire lives they have to do
something about climate change and not
just stand around doing nothing
please help save our environment and our
planet my message for world leaders is
to take action greenhouse gases can
affect the atmosphere a lot and
renewable energy can be really important
if you want to completely reduce carbon
emissions we also need to consider
options such as nuclear which although
they are non-renewable they do not
produce anti-carbon emissions and they
can be stored safely somewhere for lots
of time try and think about stuff that's
actually going to help the environment
instead of stuff that's going to benefit
certain people a wind farm where the
high winds are to produce more energy
could be really beneficial us and future
Generations are relying on the decisions
you make today help our planet and stop
climate change from affecting us the
next 70 years
or depending on you
so I ask you for my life for my friends
lives don't mess it up
if you want to add your voice talk to
your teacher about setting up an FYI
News Club at your school all the
information is on our website
right Thomas I really want to know was
this week's story fake news or was it
fact
I told you earlier that phones now have
technology clever enough to work out
when to call the emergency services
they can detect if you've had a car
accident but in America there's been a
report they're calling ambulances when
people take a ride on roller coasters
instead that news is fat
phones have been sending alerts the
local 9-1-1 communications center by
mistake
still a little way to go until phones
are cleverer than us
[Music]
that's it for this week and with so much
happening right now make sure to keep in
touch with us let us know what matters
to you from school dinners to climate
change bye
foreign